what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and today we're gonna be discussing
a character that most of you guys have
been asking for a lot of people have
been asking me for this and I don't
understand why okay I do understand why
I mean it's super clickbait Galacta the
daughter of Galactus the or the Lords of
the powers of her character I mean she
is interesting like well she's
interesting and so well you guys
understand as we go through it but um
she's definitely a character I would
love to see come back if that makes any
sense like I'd love to see galacto like
expanded on within the realm of Marvel
Comics something else that I'm also
thinking about doing too and leave a
comment let me know what you guys think
about this I'm thinking about
alternating so we'll do like origins of
powers and then Omega Beyond Omega level
and then how to kill superheroes I think
what like rotate those and like weekly
intervals so like Omega Beyond Omega
level one week and then you know origins
of powers are next week and then how to
kill superheroes that week after that I
think we're gonna go through and like
you know kind of give that a shot and
sort of see how that does the fact
remains here you guys didn't come here
to hear me rant about a schedule you
guys came here to learn about Galactus
so like a lot of the characters that we
do when we do origins and powers we
really focus on like how the character
was made as well as the incoming book
origins so in truth what will kind of
start with the real life you know real
life creation ever characters so in 2009
Marvel did something that was actually
pretty cool and pretty out of the
ordinary in that they allowed several of
their assistant editors to pitch stories
either involving obscure characters that
weren't being used in their books at the
time or characters that the assistant
editors have basically created and so
they took all these stories and
published them in a to issue anthology
series called Marvel assistants eyes
spectacular and it was in the second
issue of this series that got locked and
made her debut and a story written by
Adam Warren and following the release of
the second issue of this series Marvel
held a vote to determine which character
featured was the most popular which
Galacta one leading to her getting her
own brief digital-only miniseries those
you guys who don't know while Marvel
does release you know physical copies
which is to say comic books that you can
go into your store and buy you can also
get the exact same things on comiXology
Marvel and even DC DC does it with
injustice as well as a couple others
Marvel publishes digital-only series
which means there's stories that you
can't go into a kind of book store and
buy you have to get them digitally
there's no other way to access them but
in terms of what her income and book
origin is we initially don't know
anything about how Galactic came to be
first year she's living on earth
disguise as a young human who basically
calls herself Gally because you know she
doesn't want people to associate you
know associate her with Galactus which
kind of makes sense because you know
trying to like devour earth is not very
good for your public perception imagine
that conversation hey what's your name
Galactic wow that sounds an awful lot
like Galactus yeah I'm his daughter ah
hasn't he tried to like consume the
world before yeah pops tends to get a
little emotional sometimes I would love
that conversation that that sounds so so
much like a galactic conversation again
it's never really explained we know
where she came from or how she came to
be in one issue she visits the Fantastic
Four and Susan Richards even wonders
aloud hygge locked his mother is but the
questions never really answered would
suggest that either Marvel didn't put a
whole lot of effort into creating
Galactus backstory because they didn't
expect her to be around very long or
they simply worked saving you know the
revelation of Galactus mother for you
know something later on some story that
never really came to fruition so we can
go either way here but with regards to
her powers Galactus is very much like
her father and that she draws upon the
power cosmic now if you're not familiar
with the power cosmic it's basically
like this inexhaustible source of energy
that allows Galactus or anyone who
possesses it including galata to do
basically anything they want and in fact
according to a remark from the Silver
Surfer the power cosmic originated in
the astral plane which is basically the
place that telepaths go to when they
commune and talk to each other but
outside of that really not much has been
said on the origin and nature of the
power cosmic we don't really know where
it comes from it's just kind of assumed
that is part and parcel to Galactus
himself and the power cosmic basically
functions as a plot device that grants
Galactus limitless power because really
all it is now what didn't keep in mind
the power cosmic can be given to other
people I mean Galactus usually does it
and gives them like a portion of their
power like maybe kind of funny if
Galactus was like I made you Silver
Surfer and give you like half the power
cosmic of my self so you're equally as
powerful as me it'd be kind of funny but
usually the Herald's get like some sort
of you know asked back to the power
cosmic that's designed to complement
their powers more or less or if they
have no powers to give them powers to
serve a particular purpose like the
Silver Surfer was just a regular being
until he was made the Silver Surfer and
then he had the ability to surf the
spaceways you know every pun intended
and then you know basically served that
purpose was the whole idea behind it but
what this essentially means is that the
a limited number of appearances we
haven't really seen galata Twitter
powers on display and so we can surmise
that she can basically do everything
Galactus can do which as I said earlier
it's pretty much everything but
specifically includes invulnerability
and matter manipulation and energy and
time manipulation and you know telepathy
and telekinesis cosmic awareness meaning
she knows everything that's going on in
the cosmos at the same time and the
ability to siphon the life energy of
organisms and even entire planets
however even though she possesses
basically the same powers as her father
as Galactus she admitted her powers are
not on the same level as her father so
she is effectively a less powerful
version of Galactus now also like her
father Galactus played by an almost
insatiable hunger that must be satisfied
by consuming other beings and planets
but unlike Galactus who consumed
virtually any planet kind of depending
on the circumstances it's one of those
weird things when he first emerged in
the Marvel Universe he would consume
anything it didn't matter what it was it
wasn't until the Silver Surfer basically
showed up it was like look I'll help you
out but you can't consume planets to
sustain life and even Silver Surfer
himself wouldn't take a like just two
planets the sustained life and it was
one of those kind of packs that Galactus
made like okay fine I won't consume
planets that's a better capable of
sustaining life but for the most part he
doesn't really can you know consume
planets that are capable of supporting
life or planets that already have life
on them it's one of those weird things I
mean he did it to the court to the
scrolls but it was kind of a dire
straits when that happened but again
unlike Galactus galata actually won't
consume planets as a stain life that's
kind of a rule that she refuses to do
not only that like she won't consume
plant I won't assume any organisms that
are native to Earth and so what she does
is she seeks out invasive life-forms and
consumes those like alien parasites that
would never be discoverable by human
technology whether she can locate due to
her near omniscience now this approach
she really kind of presents her with the
problem of never being fully satisfied
and therefore having a gnawing hunger
that constantly plagues her and so think
about Galactus feeding on entire planets
and not being satisfied and then imagine
how much less satisfied eating
microscopic organisms would leave him
and that's the situation that Galacta
finds herself in not the lock to them
discovers that her hunger is being
exacerbated by a parasite living inside
of her does she dubs the cosmic tapeworm
which is actually a really really cool
name but it basically gives her a kind
of a desire to eat more
and drain more of a portion of her power
cosmic itself and so desperate to rid
herself of this parasite Galactic goes
to the Fantastic Four for help locating
the ultimate nullifier one of the most
powerful devices in the moral universe
with the ability to basically remove
anything from existence if its user has
the drive and the intelligence to pull
it off and so because of that once
Galacta obtains the ultimate nullifier
she intends to use it on the parasite
living inside her but she stopped when
Galactus appears to her and does two
things he uses a portion of his own
power cosmic to nourish her and then
increases her cosmic awareness after
which she realizes that the organism
living inside of her is actually for
lack of a better term a fetus that will
one day mature into a cosmic being like
Galactus and galata and that she herself
had once been a similar organism that
spontaneously generated within Galactus
himself did we just describe what I
think we described did we just say go
locked he was going to do what I think
we just said she was going to do oh my
god no wonder this was canceled Wow why
would they oh my god in for a penny in
for a pound we might as well keep going
that's crazy but that's the last that we
see of Galacta we don't really learn
anything about how she came into being
until the very last panel that she
appears in Marvel what were you thinking
oh my god Wow
honestly I'll leave this to you guys uh
leave a comment below I mean this is
kind of this is kind of nuts leave a
comment below let me know what you guys
think but anyway yeah like a paralegal
act is not in continuity the question
was asked of Tom Brevoort who's the
executive editor and he said no she's
not in continuity I mean you mentioned
it on his tumblr page so we'll probably
never see or hear from her again but
yeah I mean that's pretty much all we
know about her character I mean it's a
pretty short video but she just doesn't
have that many appearances and there's
not a lot of information about her but
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like if you're new here too
comments explain make sure you have the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core and I said those two things
backwards and yeah um yeah I guess I'll
catch you guys later peace
[Music]